[Music]
and do it for the fame news
somebody buy lots of pillows oh yeah
[ __ ] hate that [ __ ] you don't like
pillows uh like i like pillows
on the bed if i'm not sleeping on it
when i'm sleeping with a pillow i sleep
with one very
thin pillow a reasonable amount of
pillow too thick
i just did like thick pillows but it
actually started hurting my neck oh
interesting so
i when by the time right when i get on
bed i have like two huge body pillows
and then two small pillows
i take the other three pillows i [ __ ]
chuck them off and then
i sleep do you sleep on your back there
it feels like there's a lot of people in
my bed that i don't want there
that's why why did you even buy them
this is your own bed and you don't live
with anyone because
you're you agree with me that's amazing
well
nikki put so many [ __ ] pillows on the
bed i'm always like
i have to take off 20 pillows to go to
bed right i put the body pillows there
because they're nice when i'm not
sleeping i'm just like chilling on there
and i put it between my legs
i just want a pillow that's like this
thin to sleep on like i don't even want
to even just get a [ __ ] t-shirt and
then roll it up
i don't understand that because your
neck [ __ ] hurts no my neck hurts if i
have a really thick pillow i think cause
you have to like support the neck my
neck hurts when i have a thick pillow
because it [ __ ] it this way
so because if it's a little thinner than
sleep on your back
huh back then right because if it's like
that i can understand because i sleep on
my side and so i need to
i need a space to like i haven't been i
haven't been sleeping on my
so i was sleeping on my side before when
i was like a bigger dude
so when i ever since i lost the weight i
sleep on my back now i never
it's so [ __ ] weird and i had to get a
softer mattress
because now my [ __ ] fat ass doesn't
sink into it anymore so i had to get a
mattress topper
so i was having back pains and i was
like what the [ __ ] is going on i went to
my chiropractor he was like
i guarantee you it's because you lost
all that weight so that stiffness is too
hard for you now so it's hurting your
joints and lo and behold
no more joint pains after i got that
mattress topper wow
[ __ ] annoying but you don't like a
lot of pillows that's awesome
no we only have two pillows each and
that's like if we're watching tv or
whatever then
what about when the bed is made like in
the morning or whatever yeah two each
that's tight yeah because then it's just
so annoying for me to have the clear
shifter
me too i never had those little pillows
yeah and i'm such a super minimalist if
she's like hey we have a no pillow rule
now but all right
good i'll adapt yeah we're just gonna
sleep on a rock now you're like sick
we have 35 pillows on the bed it's crazy
like three did you film in your room
yeah
well then that makes sense because it
makes it look nice oh but not not
often oh not off the ground that's
enough for 70 pillows
you just said 35 all right here we go i
definitely am rounding up it's probably
like seven pillows
oh no 70s accurate dude yeah it's
accurate it feels like seven thank you
uh a sister of a self-hating black teen
on dr phil
says the whole story was fake oh cause
she was saying she's white
right yeah so i'm gonna show you guys
black people because they're like
beneath white people and white people
are better or something
i'm gonna show you guys the video okay
so you guys have immediate context
what the hell we're talking about nice
tip all right here we go
i know a lot of people take issue with
my beliefs
i'm white i'm a caucasian because
everything about me is different from my
african-american i have naturally
straight hair
my hair isn't nappy it doesn't require
weave my nose is not
giant like african-americans my lips
aren't
perfect they're not too big and they're
not too small big ass lips girl
my ears i don't have black people ears
because they're really
giant most americans speak get out
but when it comes to black people i
think they're all ugly and i have
nothing
to do i'm different from african
americans because i'm white
my figure is just like kim kardashian
and she's a wonderful role model
she's not white though i think like a
white person instead of a black person
i believe that i'm completely and i'm
utterly better than them like we're on
two different levels like okay
african-americans are here
i'm here white people act and think just
way more mature than african-americans
this is like a contemporary dave
chappelle's kid yeah yeah yeah
i feel like i know it is what is wrong
with them
do you guys watch atlanta no i've seen
some atlanta so
atlanta there's one episode where they
have a skit
exactly like this where there's this
dude that's like oh i believe um you
know as a joke because of the whole like
transracial like joke thing so he's like
i think i'm like a 50 year old white
dude and he's like going to the golf
course and stuff like that
it looks exactly like this except for
this is way serious
that's good well she's trolling right i
have never seen a gap in somebody's feet
as big as that ever dude that [ __ ] is
crazy dude
why people usually have gap teeth though
oh
no it was a dumb joke no it's her
proving how white she's madonna
you could put an electrical cord through
that thing dude that [ __ ] was crazy dude
yeah so her name is treasure she's 16.
when you got a black ass name though
what the [ __ ] are you talking about dude
that's a good ass name dude treasure yep
and so her mom like when they want went
on the show her mom was like i blame
myself
for the reason why my daughter thinks
she's white because i told her she was
white
pretty much because she i know i swear
no so she was married to a white man
and so she on the show she said that she
made her kids believe that they were
biracial and so when he died in 2006
that's when
she told her them like oh you're
actually not like that wasn't your real
dad
and that was what was said on the show
but then nina who's 25 years old and
she's the oldest
sister she came out on instagram live
and
pretty much debunked the whole thing she
was like no they're lying
my mom is used to living a certain type
of lifestyle
and she just wanted an all-expenses paid
trip
to la to film this and my sister all she
wanted to do was become a meme
that's a genius that's a goal for kids
life goals to become a meme yeah
why not oh here's treasure this is nina
yeah nina's
bad dude wait hold on is nina
yeah look at all the attention she got
she mission accomplished dude and free
trip
accomplished yeah so then uh she was
also saying like yeah they told me they
were gonna go to la but
they didn't say why and they just kept
saying like we can't tell you why
it's a secret and and then she was like
i thought they were gonna go on the show
for
some real [ __ ] that treasure has done
because she's a mess like she was
um she was saying that she's banned from
every single cvs
in like the whole nation because yeah
for stealing and that
she always has hustles that she's
sold like dollar store wigs to people
for like 50 bucks
and things like that they bought it good
for her that's a business
but it was like fake hair she would
claim it was real things like that
and so um and then she was she was just
so upset because
because of the fact that they used her
dad and
she was just like you know they they
disrespected
my dad and it's just [ __ ] up and this
is all a lie like
treasure has always known she was black
like she's super black like all her
friends are black like
there a clip from dr phil where he's
like you are not
why because i want it
i want to see it yeah exactly everyone's
like dr
phil tells it like it is he tells it
like it is
saying the most basic [ __ ] and he's a
solid electrician
but yeah and so also treasure is kind of
like on the run because
um she's on the lam huh yeah
cause child protective services they're
trying to get a hold of her because the
mom doesn't have custody of her
oh and because the mom oh it's because
the wait oh the previous father the
actual father or whatever
what has custody is well he's i'm not
sure who does but i just know she
doesn't and
or c yeah cps does because yeah cause i
was like who has custody
probably anybody wants customers because
she got her kids taken away or whatever
oh [ __ ] and um and then so her sister's
like she needs to do some hard time in
juvie and sit down and be in a
controlled area
uh she doesn't want help from a regular
family household
because she's supposed to be in the
system and then now she's saying that
she really
she's like worried for her because she's
getting a lot of death threats from
people
after this [ __ ] yeah yeah so she was
like she means
all black people are here i'm here yeah
that's death threat trolling as [ __ ]
it's like
like you said it's dave chappelle it's a
dave chappelle
yeah and she proved a [ __ ] lot about
the world didn't she with that like
where it's like
it's like if something if something
seems like
that crazy that shock jock radio way it
gets a [ __ ] ton of views and attention
like i love
i love what she like what the point of
it is if that's what she's making
no i don't think that's her point i
think she just wanted to be famous she
just wanted to be like the catchment
outside girl
because like yeah my bad okay from the
hustle thing from the hustle thing it
sounds like she just wants notoriety
because she thinks it'll lead to like
money or whatever the [ __ ] like to use
other people yeah but the catch me
outside girl
she capitalized on her music so what are
you gonna capitalize on gap teeth
like what's gonna happen yeah i don't
know what her i don't know what her plan
is pushing for gap that's what's gonna
happen
so what's going on guys so this is my
daughter to me this is more about our
society
than anything because she got what she
wanted yeah
everybody got what they wanted yeah now
she's on the lamb jesus
yeah exactly why are you called online
yeah i was about to say like are you on
a lamb like me
yeah why is that why is that afraid what
does that even mean huh i mean they're
on the run
yeah is it all the lamb or lamb article
because i had never heard that before
and i had to google it i'm like what's
on the land like the old americans
saying
they're on the land flight what
it means to run off it started in 1897
from yeah from the term land based
which was used yeah for beat oh okay
interesting oh jesus yield english
[ __ ] sucks i know dude
i was like but it's like but it's fun to
say like
i mean what else is like you're like
they ran away they're on the land like
well it's like how
the press they have you can't just say
the same thing again have you noticed
that they changed the words
because it has a better flow yeah yeah
she's kind of ridiculous dude that's so
sad that that's i didn't know that
becoming a meme was a goal
for young people that's a weird [ __ ]
golden be terrified if i became a meme
yeah because then you're just that pers
that you're that joke i'm terrified i
became a gif
so many times oh the dollar one the
dollar one and there's this other thing
where i just i don't know i'm like
looking over my shoulder like this
you know there's people there's people
that see michael jordan these days and
they just know him as crying face
that's insane i don't even know him as
the like greatest basketball player of
all time
they just see him as oh it's crying face
man yeah like what do you mean the
greatest basketball player of all times
lebron james
right yeah yeah yeah but out to christ
i wouldn't even want to be a meme it
depends on the meme yeah or if you have
absolutely nothing going on in your life
i can see why that would be appealing
but it's like jesus christ dude it's
gonna be like literally
i wouldn't be surprised if they even had
to like support groups for people that
have
gone through the meme support group meme
anonymous he was like hi
my name is ryan it's been 10 days
pop off and then disappear so fast
nowadays though like
the stuff that people are are so like
let's say you're like your online
personality
right and then some bad [ __ ] happens and
they're like oh my whole crew no it's
not
just give it a couple months yeah don't
feed into the negativity it'll disappear
continue to do what you're doing and
it'll go
ariana grande with the whole donut
licking thing people are angry what is
that when she licked the donut
oh i forgot about that automatically
dude like
logan paul too nobody's gonna remember
that [ __ ] he's still doing really well
you know who who killed it in my opinion
with this [ __ ]
and he's a buddy of mine is chocolate
rain dude oh it tastes all day one day
he absolutely likes is still doing [ __ ]
like 10 years later it's been 10 years
yeah what does he do
he's like doing podcasts and stuff he's
still posting videos and stuff he's
[ __ ] voice man
his voice is oh yeah it's amazing he's
like hello steve it's nice to see you
[Laughter]
you have to talk from the back of your
throat yeah
it's hello it's so distinct though and
he really i mean
you just say chocolate to anybody who's
still no chocolate acoustics of his
throat is nuts
yeah i feel like his inside his throat
is just an empty dance hall
echoey too it's gonna echo i'm like from
your throat holy [ __ ]
there's a [ __ ] podium
and he's the nicest guy ever i don't
think i've ever met a nicer person he's
a really nice person
but wait what yeah he wasn't that that
what happened to do tell what do you say
to you put them on blast let's hear it
yeah no i mean
blast them out bring that ass over here
latina
he wasn't super rude or anything it was
just not as friendly as i thought he
would be oh you [ __ ] up then you're
expecting him to be something that he's
not yeah yeah for sure it was my own
expectation
were you like do the whole chocolate
rain song no
you thought it was gonna be um no so i
was just like oh it's
on day and then he was just like and he
left i was just like
oh he's a little shy okay it's that's
the shyness thing that i don't think it
was a dick thing
no i i mean i wasn't saying he was a
dick i think you just said he was he's a
dick because
that's what he said i didn't say that
you're putting words in my mouth yeah
called gays on day is that what you call
well it not insulted anymore now it just
gets you views baby yeah
[Music]
huh